après avoir très largement consulté
notamment cours des 10 derniers jours je
les fais avec les partenaires sociaux
avec les représentants des familles avec
les délégués nationaux et académique des
lycéens
j'ai proposé au président de la
république et au premier ministre des
aménagements qui permettent de concilier
la sécurité et la réussite future des
élèves et ils ont accepté cette formule
face à une situation incertaine
nous avons donc écarté une solution
mixte qui aurait consisté à faire passer
une ou deux épreuves aux élèves et de
valider le reste de l'examen en contrôle
continu
parce que nous ne pouvons garantir de
façon absolue la tenue d'épreuves
écrites dans le calendrier prévu et au
regard des conditions sanitaires
l'ensemble des épreuves du brevet et du
baccalauréat général technologique et
professionnel sera validée en contrôle
continu
donc si je rentre maintenant dans les
détails
pour ce qui est des élèves de troisième
le diplôme national du brevet sera
obtenue à partir de la moyenne des notes
que l'élève aurait obtenu durant les
trois trimestres donc les trois
trimestres de son année de troisième
évidemment à l'exception des notes
obtenues pendant la période de
confinement dans les disciplines
concernées
je tiens à préciser ce point qui vaut
pour l'ensemble des classes dont je
parle les notes obtenues en période de
confinement ne doivent pas compter dans
le dans la période de contrôle continu
parce que tous les élèves ne sont pas à
la même enseigne
en revanche cette période de confinement
doit permettre de préparer ce qu'on va
réussir au troisième trimestre lorsqu'il
y aura je l'espère un retour le plus tôt
possible de manière inédite tous les
élèves de collège
on redonne court jusqu'au 4 juillet c
est ce que nous devons assurer à partir
du moment où il ya eu l'euro il y aura
le retour à la normale il y aura plus de
courses que d'habitude parce qu'on
réussira à fermer réellement le 4
juillet l'obtention finale du brevet
sera suspendue à un contrôle d'assiduité
autrement dit un élève doit être là
jusqu'au bout pour avoir son diplôme
national du brevet pour se garder les
élèves de première en cette fin d'année
scolaire les élèves de première devaient
passer les épreuves communes de contrôle
continu et une épreuve écrite et orale
en français
en lien avec sophie cluzel nous assurons
évidemment que les élèves en situation
de handicap conserveront de plein droit
le bénéfice de l'aménagement de
l'épreuve et nous sommes
particulièrement attentifs en ce moment
aux élèves en situation de handicap
parce que nous savons bien que la
période de confinement posé des
problèmes encore plus aigu pour eux que
pour les autres et donc tout ce que nous
pouvons faire au travers des ressources
pédagogiques mises à disposition par
internet au travers du suivi que nous
faisons personnalisé par téléphone ou
par internet
bref tout ce qui est possible nous les
faisons en lien avec le monde associatif
en particulier la note de l'épreuve
écrite du baccalauréat de français sera
la moyenne des notes obtenues par
l'élève tout au long de l'année dans
cette discipline
c'est donc là aussi la logique de
contrôle continu qui prévaut là aussi
nous ne prenons pas en compte les notes
obtenues lors de la période de
confinement mais par contre les prévôts
râle du baccalauréat de français elle
est maintenue c'est un point particulier
nous l'organiserons donc à la fin du
mois de juin au début du mois de juillet
simplement nous pouvons organiser ces
épreuves orales sauf si évidemment les
conditions sanitaires ne le permettait
pas dans l'intervalle mais dans la
mesure du possible nous organiserons
donc un oral de français simplement il y
aura moins de texte exigeait que prévu
ce sera 15 textes dans la voie générale
12 textes dans la voie technologique
c'est ses textes je le crs ont préparé
actuellement par les professeurs de
français avec leurs élèves de nouveau je
veux saluer le travail qui est fait en
la matière est de nouveau je veux
inciter à lire pendant les vacances de
printemps
c'est vrai pour les élèves de première
mais c'est vrai pour tous les élèves
pendant ces périodes de vacances de
printemps il est éminemment souhaitable
de lire des livres
vous êtes amené à fréquenter encore plus
les écrans dans cette période de
confinement les vacances doivent être
l'occasion de regarder beaucoup les
livres et d'écouter la radio d'écouté
des émissions d'écouter la musique
pour ce qui est des épreuves communes de
contrôle continu donc voilà pour l'école
pour la classe de première ce qu'on
appelle les autres à ces deux l'histoire
géographie les langues vivantes les
mathématiques en filière technologique
ne donneront pas lieu à une évaluation
telle qu'elle était prévue dans c dans
ces disciplines que je viens de citer la
moyenne qui soit retenu pourra pour le
baccalauréat sera
l'addition de la note obtenue aux
épreuves commande passée cette année ce
qu'on appelle le 3 c'est un et celles
qui seront passées en classe de
terminale qu'on appellera donc 3 c3 donc
pour résumer la note de 3 ces deux dans
ces quatre disciplines quoi
passé 1 et 2 3 c3 l'épreuve portant sur
l'enseignement de spécialité que les
rêves ne poursuit pas un terminal
puisqu'elle de première à trois
spécialités en première puis 2-1
terminal donc celle qu'il laisse à la
fin de la classe de première ainsi que
l'épreuve d'enseignement scientifique
qui fait partie du bloc commun seront
validées par les notes obtenues en
contrôle continu durant d'un coup toute
l'année par le candidat dans ces deux
disciplines
ensuite pour ce qui est des élèves de
terminale pour les élèves de terminales
générales et technologiques
l'ensemble des épreuves soient validées
par la note obtenue dans les disciplines
concernées durant les trois trimestres
trois trimestres de l'année de terminale
à l'exception des notes obtenues pendant
la période de pré finement
comme je le disais tout à l'heure les
notes déjà attribués aux épreuves
anticipées de première sont gardés donc
le baccalauréat de français de l'année
dernière est évidemment dardé l'écrit
comme à l'oral
de même les mentions du baccalauréat
sont maintenus il y aura un jury
d'examen pour examiner les livres et les
élèves autrement dit le contrôle continu
et examinées par un jury d'examen
présidé par un inspecteur général dans
chaque département de france